зараз і на завершення другові та світлове
війни міжнародного specs чині коліно
було таку кришку і як тпр за 100
ураження голови мюнхенської конференції
вольфганга та sengara класти в основі
тягу річкових дискусій проба спайку уокер
грудь доля над лицарі глав держав
то побачивши tapon від 80 міністр оборони
то закордонних справ про і в годину на
розпізнавати і викладення до заспівати це за
пуберт янове святої вінні владні bull
і за знову не в 1963 начебто так дзвони зус
три години барони та політики та кіпру 1 low
конференцію вона стала єдиним мій данчик
розумна кому і на найвищому рівні тарної
коллі, що йшов
йде на його зустрічі непокоїть проблему
соку день я зараз є підстави
конференції з русла в рази вище
кількою учасники підлоги кільки з проблем
пробіг йому впав і весь захисний sweet у
нас головних тероризм вилову конференції
пропан повіт виритої для боротьби з нею
завантажую аналог американського фбр так вже
про фокус вина в сирі це боротьба за slam
ську державою одна тема завищується для
Мінфіну низовичну вигляд але самі заходу з
москвою про ніша мюнхенська конференція
впивався в їх лаком і холодної війни і
нині
гарячим конфліктом за участь росії на
сході України
обговорювати вулицею проблеми ліберальної
демократії
настройок Європи нині на 1 знач не зростання
не 17 року розлючена з кільки сиром
один демократичних краєм і кинджал шукаю
проблем якщо твориш його ти авторитарним
шляхом
Такий ліберальна демократія над
тренді нині у США найбільшому партнеру
європейських crane фанату
дональд трамп перший американський у
завдання kipi годину вибір чаю компанії за
сумі зовсім у тривалості первинно
атлантичному альянсу cs ідея 5
експертом фундамент ніякий френсіс
оспівані вожатий що світло стоїть на порозі
так званої посади дно і риби
пуховики дамінова у західній ліберальній
святий порядок добиваючи киньте
я крутив мани у витрачаєте кришкою мер
квітів та лідери дошку туго там і 3 днів
17 по 19 лютого він infini